the real climate change risks over the
next 10 years who's telling you the
truth about them there is so much
discussion about
we've got a 10 or 12 years left before
total climate disaster uh there is no
greater believer than me in the climate
science believe I accept the climate
science to say I believe in it is not
even the right term because the climate
science is what it is regardless of
belief I accept climate science I
believe we have to act and I believe we
have to act now I also think it's
important to be accurate and sober
rather than hyperbolic about the real
risks over the next 10 years so let's
talk about what those are there are some
risks that are overblown at least when
thinking about the next decade one of
the most important risks of climate
change over the next 10 years is the
potential for more extreme weather
events and we have been seeing some of
them heat waves which are deadly
droughts which can affect food
production floods which can create and
spread disease and and cause all sorts
of other problems the negative impacts
of the extreme weather events as a
result of climate change are very real
they can damage infrastructure they can
destroy crops they can lead to death and
affect human health directly
that's a real risk and it is now and it
is a real risk over the next decade
another significant risk from climate
change is the potential for sea level
rise that's a real risk that could have
significant impacts on Coastal
communities already and over the next 10
years sea level goes up it can displace
people it can cause damage to buildings
and infrastructure their Economic
Consequences as well as social
consequences and the unrest that would
happen if large populations have to
start moving because where they live is
underwater that's a that's a real risk
now and over the next 10 years on the
other hand let me give you some examples
of less important risks particularly
over the next 10 years food production
is one often our our food production
will be destroyed by climate change and
soon is thrown out there the best
science we have right now does not
actually point that way slight global
warming
could actually be beneficial for
agriculture doesn't mean we want it but
it just it is what it is it could be
beneficial slightly higher temperatures
and slightly higher carbon dioxide
levels in the atmosphere could actually
improve crop growth and there are
studies that have shown that under
certain conditions
when you have a little bit higher
temperature a little more CO2
you can even increase crop yields like
for corn and wheat but also you can
increase the land area on Earth where
food can be produced on average so right
now you know in the future you could
have a feedback loop that maybe would
would point to it being bad for food
production but that's not actually one
that is of concern right now and that's
the best science that we have
um another example would be the
potential for slight changes in global
temperature now it's really important to
understand what I'm saying and what I'm
not saying here a rise in global
temperature can have negative impacts
but over the next 10 years the changes
from average global temperature are
likely to be extraordinarily small or
non-existent now distinguish
temperature is being slightly higher on
average is different than
acute weather events including heat
waves which absolutely can be deadly but
just it being a little bit warmer on
average is not actually the disaster
over the next 10 years that some believe
that it will be
um some folks are also concerned about
the potential for climate change to
cause widespread loss of biodiversity
and accelerate the extinction of certain
species it is absolutely true that in a
feedback loop climate change can have
negative impacts on biodiversity the
overall risks are considered very low
right now compared to other human
activities like the fact that we're
destroying habitats by clearing entire
forests as one example and polluting the
air okay so the climate change component
effect on biodiversity over the next 10
years much smaller than a lot of these
other things that we are doing so what's
the takeaway here the takeaway is it
would be best to have two things happen
number one
we talk about the risks in the realist
scientific terms and if we have a list
of 10 possible disasters but four of
them really aren't acute concerns right
now let's focus on the six that are and
number two let's actually act on the
ones that are the biggest risks because
that's going to have it's sort of like
the lowest hanging fruit in the impact
that we have if you're interested in in
this discussion the book precipice by
Toby ORD discusses a lot of what I'm
talking about uh in pretty significant
detail make sure that you were
subscribed on the YouTube channel help
us get to 2 million YouTube subscribers
it could happen sooner than later with
your help